einfach aber wasser gesucht dran freunde
sprosse gesucht und das lohnen muss ist
kommen wir machen wir beide
wir nehmen beide unsere letzten youtube
videos die nicht studieren und zeigen
was wir verdient haben damit
also berühmt sein ist für mich so ein
bisschen sogar die schattenseite von
allem nichts mehr bewegen was dem seien
wegen film sein so du bist nur
verbindungswegen fällig hallo ihr lieben
heute gibt einen neuen gast bei kimi das
ist jemand der einfach immer auf den
straßen ist wer fangen gleich mal über
ihn es ist schön garcia
für mich hier zu sein heute wirst du nur
du backen da sage ich direkt es macht
gar nichts ist besser auf die schützen
okay
wenn ich schütze schön was sagt ein fass
wein oder die farbe aus holger das hier
gedanken gemacht ja ok rot ist auch so
er so meine farbe abgeht das spiegelt
das gefährliche wieder wir machen heute
weiß ich noch gar nicht gemacht subway
cookies macadamia
okay ich habe kein wort verstanden was
das ist doch diese weise diese brötchen
oder nicht da gibt's auch diese
übertrieben beliebten
gucken jetzt jetzt habe ich gemacht
straßen interview straßen und wie ist
das so ist das verdienst teilnehmen
also damit wurde die firma aufgebaut
wir sind sehr sehr professionell
unterwegs wir haben viele leute die
davon leben mit seinem team sind gerade
da mobile meine zwei lieblinge ja ohne
die würde ich nichts zu essen haben also
wir starten jetzt mit dem tag und danach
möchte ich dich so ein bisschen aus
fragen also du kannst erst mal die
zimmer waren butter hier eingeben dann
gebe ich zucker dazu und so ist das
ganze drei minuten
zu stellen zu fragen wo du bist wenn ich
aber gut weil ich bin ja von der bak
szene und wir in der boxszene machen
dass er öfter naja getesten uns
gegenseitig ab und zu mal
[Musik]
sechseinhalb stunden später
okay ein 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
ungefähr zwischen 415 500
fast 150 gramm
[Gelächter]
fast zwei bestatter einen ding ist 25
gramm einsame weg gehen er sich so aber
das habe ich schon absehen dass wir ab
sofort testen ob
freunde da muss dann natürlich immer so
machen es ganz wichtig einzelne stehen
noch hinter stunde hiernach ich will ein
sorgfältiger typ ich bin sauber ich
komme immer pünktlich
heute ja ich war schon blut wo ich
schreibe euch alle ganz kleinen mengen
angaben übrigens unten in die infobox
falls wir das nachmachen mich ich glaube
meine mengenangabe oder auch deine also
ich habe meine
da kann auch die frage wachstum oder
kochst du zu hause ein format also ich
sage euch ganz ehrlich ne butter bei die
fische ich hab noch nie gepackt aber
kochen ja schon einmal gekocht für meine
familie
es gab
mit sahnesauce also gewürze hähnchen
angebraten aber das habe ich vor drei
jahren gemachten die harmonie wieder
nach dem gericht befragen aber ich bin
schon kochen kann nicht also ich kann
jetzt nicht nur wasser aufkochen sondern
wenn es hart auf hart kommt
also überleben kann ich wohl den mixer
und ein korso mixen
dann machst du das schon seit fünf
jahren fünf jahren wollen wir am wachsen
schon oder fünf jahre machst du das hier
sind dann mache ich das natürlich schon
seit 15 jahren aber ist heute ein
bisschen feiern hierbei spielt das
wissen wie lange also einmal für alle
die dich vielleicht noch nicht kennen
man hat sich immer um man sieht sich
immer irgendwo im internet instagram
facebook in welchem ihn sein youtube du
machst ja eigentlich den hauptthemen
sind die straßen interview so geht's
einfach aus und fragt die leute
irgendwas was machst du dir vorher
natürlich dem gedanken was was
du gehst raus guck mal hier kann man die
sache ist ich habe damals als kind wie
vision geguckt ja es war von stefan raab
auch wie man eine sendung wo stefan raab
dann so als zeit video mal kurz auf die
straße geht und einfach fragen gestellt
aber so rennt und dann ganz normal wo
waren sie denn heute sind sie einfach
süchtig ganz ganz normal und damit man
auf youtube habe ich gesehen dass es
nur krankes gibt so auf der straße die
von amerika adaptiert worden sind so und
irgendwie hat mir das nicht gefallen
weil es war so einfach zu lasch das
format idiotentest ja weil im endeffekt
fällt jeder auf so einer frage rein du
bist nervös dass eine kamera mitten auf
der straße weil es ganz was passiert da
steht die man eine frage der antwort des
einbaus nichts dann ist die falschen
lachen alle habe sagte ich gehe auf die
straße ich möchte wie damals auf die
wahl von stefan raab über vision einfach
mal so randall frage was danach passiert
es selbst nicht wissen können wenn ich
frage bist du eifersüchtig der sohn ist
ein politischer zwei frauen gleichzeitig
so fragen kannst du vorher nicht
ausdenken deswegen habe ich gesagt das
format lief von spontanität und einfach
raus lachen einfach die leute fragen die
leute sind sehr offen und ehrlich ja das
merkt man oder ist es auch so weit in
den videos denkt man gehen die nur
anspricht der quatsch direkt mit dir
wahrscheinlich nicht anders nein da war
das von 100 leute die wir ansprechen
sagen 90 jahre 10 sagen naja mutter
schnitt ja aber in die 90 sind dann so
das wissen auch die jungs wir reden erst
mal mit den leuten wie gehen nicht hin
und sagen hey wie ist deine blutgruppe
hast schon mal den ellenbogen gesehen
also was fragen gestreckt erstmal wie
geht's wer bist du ist das okay
eigentlich finde ich dass wir drehen was
machst du beruflich wenn er sagt ich bin
ich werde jetzt arzt in zwei wochen sage
ich okay
dann mal weg wochen video vielleicht
wegen polizei studium man weiß ja nicht
wie die arbeitgeber reagieren also sind
wir schon sehr vorsichtig boxt und es
sind sie gut weil es gibt ja auch andere
straßen
der user da wird so permanent ins
lächerliche gezogen hat man das gefühl
ja das stimmt leute deswegen ist nicht
gut das du darauf achtet dass die leute
auch nicht so lächerlich rüberkommen es
ist ja wirklich so und hat letztens
sogar einen der war es habe ich mal ein
guter war der erst 17 gewesen
besitzer nach deutschland gekommen sie
hat dann mit 21 seine ausbildung
genossen und das fand ich schön dem hast
du eine ganze folge gewidmet
ja das waren es mega man muss immer so
ein bisschen so ich will natürlich
spielen comedy format wird man will man
will ja lachen aber so ein bisschen
moral und muss man immer mit geben nicht
gut so eine kleine message am ende dass
man sagt ey guck mal in diese richtung
geht wir lachen natürlich wir lachen
nicht über die leute sondern mit den
menschen zusammen gibt ja viele
sympathische leute die machen spaß die
kommen sind einfach gut drauf lachen
machen sich aber bis zum affen und es
gibt den leuten sagen herr der iss dome
besteht aber nicht der typ hat seinen
spaß am leben und ich bin so leute geil
die einfach so rennen sachen machen
sagen ich sitze drei minuten drei
minuten da er
oft natürlich auf stufe vier ja genau
ich gieße man sich in reichweite
wir fangen natürlich erst mal leicht an
[Musik]
aber es gibt schon im jahr
hamar so sehr gut gemacht wie butter ist
schön fluffig geworden das könnten nur
profis muss ich sagen
dass gewisse und traurig
wirklich jetzt gibt es ja so dass gleich
auch noch mal kurz vorbei
leute wie anstrengend das ist das
anstrengend aber mein arm tut mir immer
noch
männer
einmal wasser kisten schleppen sich
erzählt ist einfach die ganze familie
einfach aber schon wasser gesucht dran
erfreuen die sprosse gesehen und was
frauen mussten die schwer und tanken
unseres nokia keinen respekt ich habe ja
auch ich habe ja auch meine community
gefragt ob sie etwas über nicht wissen
man weiß dem ist auch kraß man fast gar
nicht so viel über dich
also leute
zum ersten mal finnland sowie gesagt ich
bin
beim
nächsten mal ich habe ein interview oder
gemacht was wirklich sehr viral gegangen
ist
es kommt einfach darauf an wer mir die
richtigen fragen gestellt was die leute
wollen immer die fünf fragen müssen
bist du das bist du dies bist du das
noch keiner fragt mich was über meine
person mich erzählt sie es kommt darauf
an aber ich glaube heute werden wir viel
über mich erfahren ich hab's im urin
ja das geht nicht das shoppen
drücken wir perfekt wer gut ist so
feiern bis
18 also ich würd 18 er sieht man auch so
dass ende gute pflege oder
das ist ich gehe einmal im jahr bis zu
den
bergen in der nähe von indien die luft
ist der hammer ist es nicht mal hier mal
da und gehe dann lauft dann mit zu
diesen leuten dann ja diese gepäck
ablaufsteuerung ja und da sind wir nur
so steiner man kommt so ganz kleines
wasser raus dieses quellwasser genau ja
ja und da und eine ziege ist genosse
quelle und schlüpft damit der zunge das
wasser und den restlichen drop von der
zunge ist ganz wichtig fange ich dann
auf und bringen es dann nach hause und
macht daraus dann creme sowie hier
siegen
und untergrund bis jetzt einen markt wie
wie stets in fenstern du bist ja auch
einer ich bin keine inflation nein das
stimmt nicht wie so dass ein vorwurf den
du nicht beweisen kannst also ich glaube
sondern ist soweit okay im trend
so was mich schauen wir mal die
attribute eines impfpflasters andere
stimme habe ich nicht ja das habe ich
nicht zweitens
ich habe familie [ __ ]
drittens was noch
nein ich bin ja
vielleicht es gibt ja auch ausnahmen ja
es gibt ja auch ein einhorn vielleicht
weiß ja nicht aber spaß beiseite in
friends ich denke ich bin keinem plan
ich denke ich bin ein entertainer der
medienbranche
instagram bisschen youtube ist in
facebook und entertainer die leute ich
würde sagen ich bin entertainer man kann
mich nicht auch als journalist sehen man
kann nicht irgendwie dass sich comedian
bin ich bin kein stand up comedian ist
es entertainer sein aber ich denke nicht
dass schon interesse weil insolvenz
seien also am ende des tages machte er
nichts anderes
als nichts tun was macht eine empfehlung
zur influenza geht in hi leute ich bin
da und da ich mach das und das team
seien wegen fame sein so du bist nur
fake es gibt viele von dem was du
beschreibst wirklich ich habe das gefühl
98 prozent und wenn jetzt diese zwei
prozent die testen ein produkt die
gucken ist das kann sich wirklich
beschäftigen sich damit und dann mache
oder nicht nur sachen die gut ich glaube
dass mal jemand auch solche leute diese
einheit wurde und ihre aufgaben gefahren
sind zum beispiel genau es gibt also kg
hat schon bericht gesagt 89 2 prozent
nutzen das wirklich den könig das
natürlich vom herzen ich sage dann die
möglichen produkt testen das aber
einfach hinkommen hey leute jeden tag
ist das andere produkt so krass alles
ist krass dass mal was so vor kurzem
wegen gegen kanada eltern aus ja das ist
ganz traurig also damit müssten
eingeschränkt weil die ganzen mädels da
draußen diese kleinen kiddies die wollen
ja nicht mehr einfach sie selbst sein
sie wollen anders aussehen keiner sieht
mehr so normal aus es gibt keine in form
sein müssen längere nase und eine kleine
nase kleiner augen große augen meine
wange bist du dick gibt es nicht mehr
alle sind gleich aus wie so eine
schablone aber entscheidung war also
fand ich super von dir dass du das als
man auf angesprochen hat immer mein
handy
ich will dass sofort kann man nur die
reaktion ich sage dir das bild warum das
interview was jetzt so reagieren dass
warum ich das überhaupt gesagt haben
wegen diesem bild das hat dass das hart
wie fillinger villinger werde vor einer
von denen wird vermisst und wir haben
bilder
würden
[Applaus]
hey meine freunde wissen
ausgeliehen ich war einmal bei einem
radiosender vor einem jahr habe ich das
thema schon mal im radio angesprochen
ich will jetzt nicht sagen wer es war
das hat mir so leid getan da habe ich
auch überdies keine jenner dinge
gesprochen dass frauen also dass mehr
frauen dieses diesen druck haben
irgendwann echt muss auch so aussehen
weil sonst will mein mann nicht mich
nicht mehr weil das jeden tag irgendwo
sie im fernsehen auf instagram und
irgendwann ich erzähle einfach schade
mich in rage eine halbe stunde und
irgendwann sind zu ende das überhaupt
nichts zu lachen eigentlich und ich sie
wie die frau reise sind einfach bei also
die tränen runter laufen man sagt es ist
alles okay die so etwas hat mich berührt
was du jetzt gerade gesagt hast bei
meinem mann machten spielten so einer
verlassen weil er gesagt hatte du hast
keine aufgespritzten lippen dort das
nicht dass dies nicht so dass gas ist
traurig und hat sie verlassen und sie
wollte sich jetzt war kurz davor sich zu
operieren und nein mach das nicht bleibt
einfach so wie du bist wo ich habe
einmal mit dem arzt gesprochen habe ich
gemeint einfach macht es denn nicht so
natürlich es gibt ja leute wenn sie zum
beispiel eine kleine brust haben oder
irgendwas das verstehe ich wenn die
wirklich darunter leiden und irgendwann
so komplexe kriegen dadurch verstehe ich
das aber dann hast du ja für dich ein
fehler aber
allerdings nehmen jetzt viele leute
diese ausrede ich habe ich leider so
seit darum geht sich gut weil man so ich
möchte gerne so ohren haben und bin ich
schon dabei bin mal schon noch so lippen
das solle wissen so man nimmt diese
grauzone als auch sommer schlug dadurch
genau und habe ich gemeint ok baum gibt
es kein gesetz dass man erst mal unter
18 jahren keine operation stattfinden
auch wenn die eltern also
eine vollmacht geben oder unter 18 schon
mal gar nicht weil mit zwölf
feuerwehrmann mit 14 90 arzt werden mit
16 wollte ich rapper werden mit 18
wollte schauspieler werden wer ist für
uns mit 25 was ich mit 16 gedacht habe
gleich operiert mich komplett und dann
will ich ganz anders wieder aussehen ja
deswegen das ist so ein thema was mich
so ein bisschen aufregt und man müsste
eigentlich den ganzen ärztekammer seine
leute das darf erst operiert werden du
hast ein erstgespräch und hast du
minimum ein jahr zeit bis zur operation
um noch mal nachzudenken er vielleicht
will ich doch dass mich ja das ist ein
guter ansatz aber den meisten geht es
hier darum ja so sieht es aus wenn ich
meine politik wäre
wenn du jetzt nicht konnten creator
gewonnen wäre es was wärst du dann
geworden
ich glaube dann hat vier also in vielen
aufgaben für dich du musst an das meer 1
7 aber strom
und gucken was nicht so viel daneben
geht okay und ich denke noch wacker dazu
und natürlich den finger ja und darauf
tippen
so richtig was lernen hier also das was
aber glaube ich logisches denken aber
jetzt kommt wie eine lawine es kann sein
dass der dass der sturm kommt
ok ich hab's gleich komme jetzt fängt an
das thema geduld jetzt richtig dreckig
und das nervt mich was mache ich jetzt
hier
jetzt hab ich hier ja ich war so
etwas
wie
das ist nicht so wie man noch nicht über
geistert ja okay und jetzt ist sie so
drauf man ist es runter
okay aber jetzt ne frage nämlich ernst
warum wirft man das nicht einfach direkt
können warum so sieht haft das kommt
doch am ende des tages ausgleichen
[Musik]
ich habe gehört du kannst richtig guter
englischen das weißt du mit mir ich
dachte die wollen das erste leute
ehrlich ich damals kannst dich ja die
haben alle gesagt du kannst perfekten
übertrieben
das ist
eine handels gramm futter
swift
und
dies like rainbow show
du musst es jetzt nur einmal alles
hintereinander kurz verrühren das ist
das verdienst kurz genau mit gefühlen
wenn ich das gleich dass mesut und ich
gebe dann marc adam in estland eine 550
die packung die was schön bei eur
15 2 ich sammle die selber zusammen
stimmt dann fangen wir an verwertete
aber
den backofen schon vorgeheizt und jetzt
können wir die kekse wir machen zwei
welche weil die werden noch die gehen
noch weiter ja natürlich noch mal 14 uhr
ist hier ab sowie videos loser bei kabel
eins maja wir gehen nicht in die breite
die gegner andy
das ist doch müssen wir müssen ein
bisschen spaß da ja müssen spaß muss
sein so wie roberto blanco das ist dass
roberto blanco tunesien ein
roboter bleibe ja aber sein vater
botschafter ja und der hat indonesien
gelebt er ist da geboren okay aber ist
er dann tunesier oder nicht
jetzt habe ich eine frage die
interessiert mich okay drehen aber auch
viele haben nicht das gefragt kannst du
von deinen straßen liebesleben ja
kraftvoll die werbung da drin machst du
das
so kommen wir machen wir beide wir
nehmen beide unsere letzten
youtube-videos geliebte studium und
zeigen was wir verdient haben bist du
dabei
erika vor der kamera ok warte mal körbe
machen da ist das erste mal ja ich auch
gibt sondern ok alles klar du hast
wahrscheinlich eine million märz ist
weil du hast schon gute aufrufen aber
ich weiß davon meinen sein dass davon
gar nicht leben kann also eigentlich
nichts über lebenskunst wo nicht viel
ich will den vom volk
haben wir das ist sogar noch ein gutes
video
aber es sind ja immer so klappt manchmal
auf einmal ist es vielleicht nur das
gleiche auch wie du also das ist ganz
unterschiedlich aber
social media' youtube ist ja nicht meine
einzige einnahmequelle
ich mache jetzt zwei läden auf
ich mache einmal eine
sag mal ein restaurant mit eiscafé auf
eine sehr schöne straße bei uns in
wiesbaden und mainz weiter laden wird
ein restaurant sein mit china aber so
wie man es in urlaub kennen zeugen in
der türkei features nur eine nebensache
dokumente und die location ist direkt am
see direkt am see wir haben knapp
1000 quadratmeter grundstück der
terrasse man kann ein bisschen boot
fahren es gibt einen kleinen strand
macht allein oder neue partner waren
aber ich schaffe das nicht noch mal
heißt das dass
youtube läuft eigentlich aber ich bin ja
auch fest ich mache ja auch werbung ist
ja nicht so
versteckt dass gut versteckt ist
eigentlich nicht so bei mir sind
kooperationen eigentlich eine sache von
ich gehe jetzt nicht studieren das auge
sondern zb wir haben eine geile
kooperation für die tour vertrags zum
beispiel nur die klamotten und erwähnen
sie so das war es aber jetzt hier mit
1000 rabattcodes habe ich mal gemacht
muss schon mal zu geben war ich auch mal
kurz in dem film aber das mache ich so
nicht drin ok also ich muss ehrlich
sagen
dass gerade sagen wohin gehen
aber ich finde das sei die auch gegönnt
aus dem team hinter dir du stehst du du
planst du machst du arbeitest viel und
deswegen es muss so eine zahl dabei
rauskommen ja das ist jetzt schon gelegt
selbst auch zum ersten mal eine frage
erst mal
schäme mich immer nur für mich schon
unwohl weil eigentlich so ein geld
zeigen
sollte man nie machen aber weil es noch
welche fragen oft kam bist du millionär
nein warum kein wort kommt diese fragen
ich sage dir was ich will wenn du wenn
du wirst es auch sagen dass ich sie
fragen ja ein
nein also torschützen sich sagen weil
ich finde das hat gar nichts über mich
zu heißt oder so personen das problem
ist dieses millionär sting hat nie sagen
mein leben ich mache eine capri sonne
auch jakob mahl das millionär dir in
kappel sonne hat eine andere strom
verlegt da kriegt nur dass dann geben
machte eine in story wir waren sind nach
dubai geflogen und die historie des es
gibt ja so ein zwei gänge und die hat
mich also die war dann bisschen weiter
vom hat mich als erstes gefragt seines
duells ist sozusagen die an ihnen
vorbeikommt war noch ein bisschen
internet sagt kuck leute nur millionäre
werden als erstes gefragt ich sitze hier
ich habe nur ich bin halt ein flugzeug
kriegt nix der wird gefragt ob ein
handtuch will das nur mir hat das ins
leben gerufen er hat irgendwann werde
ich überfallen und schlange ich die
leute zusammen bei phoenix habe sagte
lüke millionär guck mal wie weit das t
shirt kostet sage ich zwar möglich dass
apollo gekostet ich kenne das da wo
keine marke drauf steht das kostet 300
euro also schöne grüße an dieser danke
für diesen ruf als millionär aber es
gibt sicher schön aber
so leute ich bin zwar kein millionär
aber ich bin reich im herz denn ich habe
euch
ich habe euch und wenn ihr da draußen
so sein wollt wie ich dein kopf mein
produkt für 7000 euro
zusammen für 7000 euro du bist dann zwar
arm dass sie krank
so also schauen wir haben ihn also
besser gesagt auf den tag vorbereitet ja
das wort sagen
so jetzt kannst du aber mit nicht ganz
voll machen noch zu drei vierteln nicht
zu groß werden stich sie dem abteil und
dann machst du so sechs problem ich habe
früher im eiscafé garrett ich hoffe
aufgehalten was du gemacht
so man muss natürlich das eigentlich
kurz an feuchten aber das machen wir
jetzt weil der teig so fleißig ist
unsere schulden das
ist ja das logic also man muss das was
uns nun zu viel blut testen ich wollte
schon gut gucken uns verstanden dass das
thema schwanz buddhisten so
machst du so mit ein bisschen abstand
nummer sechs auf einem blech so weil es
geht noch in die breitungen haben
ja perfekt also abschluss
ich habe mit haupt angefangen
hauptschule ich wollte nie gut in der
schule nicht jetzt kann man sagt ich war
nur faul einfach ja intelligent war ich
immer das wurde mir gesagt hast du
überhaupt nicht von mir selbst
hauptschule gemacht habe ich eine
ausbildung gemacht
als mediengestalter
also machst du eigentlich das was du
gelernt hast genau
so ich habe auch bis bis vor
bis zur wanderung ist vor noch einen
monat nach einer mona habe ich meine
videos auch alles selber gemacht noch
selber geschnitten und so jetzt brauche
ich natürlich die diese talentierten
jungs da drüben die
natürlich auch ein neues will neuen wind
in meine videos reinbringen die das
können die mich hier am besten entlastet
entlasten dass ich mich im wald auch
viele andere sachen konzentrieren kann
und ich möchte am ende des tages ich
möchte nicht berühmt sein also berühmt
sein ist für mich so bisher sogar die
schattenseite von allem ich möchte
einfach nur künstler sein ich will
menschen zum lachen zu bringen lachen
lachen zu bringen
ich verstehe einfach letzt menschen zum
lachen zu bringen jetzt ein richtiger
zu lassen
freut sich falsche oder
aber ist es so über der so lässt sich
die stadt wird erkannt du bist du ich
hab kein bock eigentlich aber ich muss
jetzt neu also das gitter es geht
eigentlich darum ich freue mich immer
sehr wenn leute mich ansprechen
und war gut
auch wenn ihr von dieser sonst kriegen
wir so machen wir kommen pro titel wo
ist das handy nicht mehr geläutet haben
immer so also dann machen die noch mal
rein aber ich für dieses
[Musik]
monats will ich weiß dass haye lässt
keiner wieso müssen wir rein und man
ungefähr so
richtig großen teller für
leute denken denn wirklich jetzt wäre
aber ich will wirklich drin haben weil
es schmeckt ja getragene
das gerät komplett aus geläufig glaube
ich
warum sagt in kassel sind ist also
[Musik]
ich habe uns noch ein paar macadamia
aufkommt packen nämlich oben dran so gut
aussieht und jetzt ist wichtig weiß bei
euch zu hause manchmal keinen dampf stoß
beim backofen das doch für die kekse
superwichtig macht ihr die hände ein
bisschen was also gibt ja und am schluss
ist es natürlich schon ein problem ja es
wirklich sie ja nur dadurch werden die
sauce oft gibt es sie habe ich immer
egal wo ich bin damit stoße dabei ruhig
ein bisschen mehr
so und jetzt musst du so schnell ist
heute teil ja das wird kann auch
entspannt sein das war jetzt die jeden
text einzelnen forderten so schnell geht
sagt also legt
man imitiert den dampf stoßen ich habe
das fenster oder hier diese
nehmen wir das war das programm musik
wenn das wasser ja prophezeit
so schnell du kannst dieses geld ist
doch dieses kennst du das nicht ich
mache sie vorsorglich noch gemacht
dagegen sind sophie egal der krieg wird
nicht gemacht richtig dreimal
ja
ein bisschen schneller und schneller
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich da merkst du dass du
verstehst
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ja
gesagt ich
habe ein video von ihr gesehen hast du
gesagt das ist vertreten ich spring
design
ich habe lange aufgehalten ich starrte
mich schon horst ich mir dachte was hat
aber gesagt komm ich war mal mit aber
ich war so jetzt dem gedanken dass zumal
sie hat das sehr schlau gemacht da muss
es doch mal am tag sein und ich hab mich
dann konzentriert wie sie es meint
[Musik]
reingefallen
aber eins stimmen wir machen wirklich
bisschen mit wasser liegt das team
wirklich frische mit dem flachen drücken
damit die nicht kenntlich macht den
macht den letzten
gut dass ich die vorbereitung trafen die
leute auf der straße
[Musik]
da guck mal was eine schöne werbung war
jetzt machen wir hier guck mal hier
ist doch schön perfekt wenn ich schmeiße
du nicht war die wahl noch
drei sekunden agenda ich weiß nichts
wegnehmen 3d funktion
ja ich bin heute mit einem kleinen
geschenk noch zu dir gekommen denn ich
bin ja auf tour deswegen war mein erster
stopp bei dir mein allererster stoff von
der großen tour ich wollte einen
schinken
ich wusste das nicht anziehen wenn du
nicht willst kannst du ihm geben
du musst das anziehen des bag zu hören
hier sind ein das in situ dates
ja eigentlich die buchung stehen das
schreiben wir noch drauf was heute
einfach mal geht es auch die erste wie
das t shirt geschenkt bekommen
[Applaus]
sehr kurz ich mir direkt amt so wenn ich
dann irgendwann mal in las vegas bin
kannst allen kommentaren t shirt ich
manchmal ein penner bin irgendwo in
saarbrücken und kann so auch zeigen oder
weil er selbst kenne aber
[Gelächter]
okay also die fix und fertig gebacken
das sind wunderschöne kekse wir finden
uns schon sehr schön schön sehr
appetitlich
hab gestern auch ein bisschen was
vorgebacken also hier schon mal damit
wir auch genug raum zum parteien okay da
wo sie sehen schon bevor ich ihnen das
kein unterschied hier das sind die von
subway ich würde sagen schön com probier
mal okay weiterbilden verkostung das was
wir machen gar nicht in form weil ich
gucke gut okay so ich geh jetzt ich sage
mich was ich die gebe ja das sind die
das ist erst vorsichtig gebe ich hier
nicht weiter ich glaube jetzt kommen nur
knallharte also erste dass ersteres
haben
das war etwas bisschen pfälzisch auf der
zunge baldigen abgang aber dann doch ein
bisschen spritzig im raum
[Musik]
und das erste mal
dass das erste von subways und
das ist von uns okay wie findest du das
zweite nach meinem geschmack ist das
zweite besser weil ich mag es ein
bisschen das drauf beißen kann
und das nicht ich denke dass ich
mit dem mund habe okay weil wir hier mit
konstant ist bröselt in meinem mund
genau geprüft und das mag ich okay okay
dass sie die binde ruhig abnehmen
auflösung das erste bei uns ist das
zweite wasser vor warum bei uns soweit
er keine ahnung deine bewertung gewesen
als wir sagt man besser im endeffekt das
ist industrie das kannst du vergleichen
wir haben mit liebe gekocht es stimmt
wir mit liebe gekocht auf jeden fall
nein ich hab dich hereingelegt und das
für umgekehrt gewesen also das ist davon
ist bei uns
sowieso
so man gucken was die leute auf der
straße sagen sie seien auch schon
gegeben
wir wollen jetzt ein eigenes land frage
was war das größte interesse hat es
nicht geklappt erste interview gesagt
dass du bist nach hause was wir das
jetzt das bekloppt ist anhänglich
bekommst du das
erste interview ja wo ich sogar angst
hatte aber nie veröffentlicht nein warum
wir sind passiert die geschichte noch
nie erzählt ja heraus ich habe jemanden
interviewt
und treppen gefragt hey wie gehts dir so
gut dir ganz normaler typ sonnenbrille
rucksack an alles gut sagt
ach so bist du eine beziehung hast du
unsere frauen hat zu nähe
ja in meinem früheren leben hatte er
aber die kinder die stadt hatte das sind
dann gekommen und sie sind dann in die
neue welt gekommen ob die neue welt des
causa deswegen müssen wir zurück in die
alte welt
und ich hab's lagerte
und dann sagt er kommen beginnt mit
kommen mit in die alte welt weil die
neue welt und irgendwann nach einer
halben stunde habe ich abgebrochen weil
er auch dann hinterher gelaufen hat er
gesagt wir müssen darüber reden möchte
jetzt durch die kamera durchkomme und
durch die leute gehe dann kommen wir
alle in die alte welt und dann sagt er
irgendwann so
hast du jetzt wirklich kind oder dich ja
sechs aber in der 200 neuen welt und
vielen alten ich habe ja schon mal
gelegt und so und da habe ich gesagt
okay abbruch
40 also ganz also das war so ein wo ich
sagte okay das war es erstmal angst
bekommen ab sofort jemanden okay aber
das lustigste video mein lieblings video
ist der kleine italiener mit dem
bügeleisen
wir hatten ja das bleibt mein top wo er
wo die frau sagt ja ich habe mal mit dem
glücklosen schlag doch das habe ich
gesehen die waren so voller liebe und
sympathie gehen auch ein bisschen
stimmiger er war so klein die waren so
lustig ja ich rufe ihn sogar silvester
manchmal
ist es
klar ich sagen schlägt immer noch mit
bügel sind ein bügelbrett die nicht am
noch einige gefragt über dich was nicht
auch brennend interessiert wo siehst du
dich in zehn und 20 jahren obdachlos
gemacht
quatsch nächsten zehn jahren sehe ich
mich
immer noch in der entertainment und
medienbranche ob ich auf youtube stadt
sondern weiß ich nicht ja man weiß nie
was die zeit bringt aber auf jeden fall
in den bereich waren das was mir immer
schon gelegen dieser bereich aber ich
denke dass ich dann richtung geschäfte
auch gehe immobilien gehen werde aber
immer irgendwas mit medien machen weil
ich liebe das ich will ja auch mit
dieser auch irgendwann der podcast tor
machen eine riesengroße tor das heißt es
heißt dort kannst du das heißt das was
wir im podcast machen machen wir einfach
vor zuschauern wir reden machen spiele
interagieren mit den leuten dann
zuschauern wollen dann irgendwann mal
der testtour machen nach kohlers denkmal
so 10 test städte und wenn das gut
funktioniert vielleicht ende nächstes
jahr ist oder darauf dass ja wenn alles
so gut klappt direkt 40 städte dann auch
mal bis eine andere tour und wir haben
jetzt schon eine riesen tour gerade wo
wir uns jetzt befinden heute der erste
tag genau wir haben einen monat vor uns
und wenn das alles natürlich gut läuft
und alles so was will ich nächstes jahr
sogar eine europatour machen einen
reibungslosen erst einmal schön risse
gehen an messages ja wir haben jetzt
nach vorne
wir sind
sind am start der natur das video online
geht dann geht die tür auf dann habt ihr
eine halbzeit gewonnen müsst ihr
unbedingt die städte abdecken in denen
noch keiner dazu kommen einfach dazu
kommen haben es gibt geschenke wir haben
über 2000 shirts dabei wir haben handys
dabei wir haben alles mögliche ich habe
natürlich auch schon ein bisschen was
von ihm geklaut jaja haselnuss krämer
scream das leben von kiki das wären wir
auch verteilen
es werden nochmals straßen interviews
seien kostenlos könnt ihr dann zum
nightliner kommen zum bus wir verteilen
wir reden wir machen fotos wir lachen
backhus videos für opa oma für brüder
und alles kostenlos alles umsonst
natürlich kein interesse
du machst kein geld mit der natur mann
ist alle können gratis alles was diese
reingekommen ist es geht auch direkt
wieder raus null auf null wir wollen
nichts zu verlieren wir wollen einfach
ein statement setzen wir wollen uns
etablieren wir wollen sagen es geht ein
nächster schritt scheint es ja schön
also wir gehen jetzt wieder ein paar so
impressionen zu dem was wir gleich
machen und den rest später dann bei mir
fing schon bei ihm auf dem kanal also
kommt vorbei kommt drüber geht es war
mir eine ehre war justin wirklich zu mir
ehre das hat mir sehr viel spaß gemacht
ich komme jetzt hastig der früher sein
ich habe einfach nur so vorbei und
klingelt ich habe den schlüssel nach
geprägt wie traurig nicht weil so der
sagt ja jetzt sagte ja und und sagte
später nein da kommentiert auf jeden
fall wie ihr diese folge findet ich
hatte megaspaß gemacht und wir sehen uns
dann auf seinem kanal bis dann
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
dazu gebracht die wollen ja nur
kosmetik ist
komplexer